we were they had this uh big tech
hearing on on um
monopolies earlier today and a lot of
people are really disappointed
in basically everybody of course yeah
all the politicians are just you know
they're unable to actually do anything
and i look at it and i'm like what what
i was saying before the show we're
talking about it now is like i think
that people who get into politics
are the people who aren't skilled enough
to actually make it on their own in a
meritocracy
but they are will they are smart enough
to be a puppet for
certain industries so if they need the
money to get elected
they can yeah sure i'll adopt whatever
cause you want me to adopt
and this is democrats and republicans
alike it's like what's that pro-life and
pro-gun
sure i'll say whatever you want me to
say hire me and then i'll get paid
whereas you wonder why it is that the
talented intelligent people who know
what they're doing know what they're
talking about won't do it well it's
because they're gonna go start a
business and make tons of money yeah
who wants like who who would want to go
work in politics
it's extremely expensive very difficult
to win it is brutal everyone hates each
other
and you don't even get paid that much
the amount of effort you got to put in
to get into office
you end up with people like aoc
well why are they all so rich then well
old money
so so we got a lot of them yes okay so
so we got a bunch of old money people
controlling everything i don't like that
i don't like that
i i don't i don't i think we need a a
big huge
boost of a younger generation in
politics
yes period there have been moments of
the people in in congress where like all
the incumbents get booted out
really yeah how many times does that
happen i don't know i don't think that
many only a couple
there was one i think there was a chart
i was looking at of like democrat versus
republican overlap
okay and they used to overlap quite a
bit now they're extremely far apart
but in the chart you could see weird
gaps and then they pointed out like the
new york times i think saying like at
this point
the overwhelming majority of incumbents
were voted out wow it was like the
american people revolting and saying
everybody
that's the best thing about our
government is that
it act there can actually be a
revolution in the sense that
every single politician in office can be
removed within a couple years two to
four years
or six let's do it let's see yeah rid of
them all
but but it's not necessarily that simple
right nothing is
i fully agree with you i think the issue
is not so much
incumbents i think it's nobody
not enough people care that's also
another problem
so you end up add one more problem to
the list of what
is wrong with the society we live in
yeah but look at um
you know mackenzie bezos okay she just
dumped 1.7 billion into
social justice organizations like
full-on intersectionalism
because she cares and i'm sitting here
like man
there's there's how do you how do you
come compete with that level of cult
power almost two billion dollars being
dumped into the cult
i mean uh there there was a a large
chunk of that that went to minority
schooling and that i i have no problem
with i mean there's there's
yeah i don't know where all the money's
going but i i did see that there is a
large chunk that's going to minority
communities and i i'm okay with that
like there's nothing wrong with that i
got you look i
i have concerns about the power of
billionaires to influence everything
around us
especially when they're all pushing the
same thing like open borders
yeah and you know things like that and
intersectionalism
because intersectionalism is reactionary
and it wants to revert this country back
to an identitarian rule of law
we got rid of all that stuff yeah we
used to have laws based on race and
we're like nah we're not gonna do that
anymore
why because we got a bunch of immigrants
who live here now
that money is gonna go towards that kind
of ideology and spreading it even
probably with many of those schools
so like how do you how do you compete
against that when most people don't care
and just sit back i guess
then that's that's how the change
happens we got to fix our schools
that's something that i've i've been
very very firm about for
over a long time actually since i was
younger since i was in school and i was
like why are we learning this what what
is this what is this
this isn't important i mean i think i've
had a conversation about that with
almost
everybody that i went to school with and
you think about what we're learning
what they're teaching we see these
teachers are teaching
how racism exists it's like why aren't
we teaching that racism is a past tense
thing like we gotta like
we gotta teach to the future not teach
to the past
because the teachers are in the cult i
know exactly they're teaching the other
thing that we gotta do another add
another
problem to the list they're they're
teaching the 16 19 project yeah that's
messy and the woman who wrote it just
admitted it's not even a work of history
it's not it's yeah she said it was a
narrative memory or something some weird
she's like it was never meant to
actually be historical it's just an
origin story
it's like yeah right what does that even
mean you knew exactly what you're doing
when you set that in motion
the new york times you can see the
moment they gave up and decided to just
become buzzfeed with the thin veneer of
academia right
and so they're like hey if it if it
offends people and will get us clicks go
for it
cnn does the same thing i mean come on
cnn brought on jeff zucker
he's literally nbc's reality tv guy
yeah he was like i got an idea let's
turn the news into reality tv and cnn
was like great if it makes money
all of these people in all of these
institutions
are basically saying we're gonna watch
the whole thing
burn to the ground and extract as much
as we can while it happens
and that's what i'm seeing now as they
pump out more money
in stimulus more money and i tell you
what i see these memes right
there's a meme going around where it's
like if you're upset that your neighbor
is getting six hundred dollars
a week from unemployment you should
really be mad at the employers
your your employer for not paying you
more money and i'm like
if the government guarantees one hundred
percent of your wages plus six hundred
dollars
there's literally no circumstance in
which any business could compete with
that because no matter how much you pay
they'll get six 600 more yeah now there
is an unemployment cap i think
but they said 100 i don't know exactly
how it works
the point is man they're printing out
money they're watching the whole thing
burn to the ground
and they don't care they don't because
they're super rich
that's it when they talk about
abolishing the police they don't care
they can hire security
exactly exactly so you see people like
mackenzie bezos who's dumping all this
money into all of these these programs
and everything
some of which apparently are in favor of
abolishing and defunding the police
that woman is going to want she will
never want for anything again
she could hire 10 times the private
security
in fact you know the craziest thing is
if you're rich enough you can hire
security who literally breaks the law
for you
so like i've seen videos where people
have international private security
they'll punch a cop in the face no
straight up
i can't remember which video i was
watching where the cops were like trying
to move through and the private security
shoved the cops
nope they get paid way too much they're
like i get paid
mid six figures through the security job
and i got the best lawyers in the world
you ain't stopping me you're a beat cop
making 27 000 a year
so you get someone with 60 billion
dollars in hard assets mind you who can
convert that
they're going to have 10 layers of
security guards and you're not going to
do anything against that
you defund the police no one's going to
be able to to come and arrest them for
anything sounds corrupt
yikes yeah man this is what i feel like
as of late there's a lot of
elites that know that everything's
crumbling
you know they're they don't care they
don't
like already set up definitely and what
have we seen
metals have been spiking people are
buying up silver and gold like crazy
they're buying up properties in the
middle of nowhere montana idaho iowa
house is under 400k there's there's
there's articles popping up all over the
place warning the dollar collapse is
imminent
whether or not that actually is i don't
know yeah and talk of war
coin shortages and i look at what the
politicians are doing and i'm like i'm
pretty sure
when all of these people with pitchforks
and torches start screaming
print more money and just give it to me
the politicians are like
well it's burning down whatever
i'm not going to do what needs to be i'm
not going to do what needs to be done
i'm just going to do whatever i feel
like
just because it's the end a small sliver
of them are saying that yeah sure
politicians
no no the people that scream print more
money give it to me it's not a small
percentage dude it's it's it's massive
what's the what's the percentage when
you have every single progressive
activist
and all of their followers i mean we're
talking about probably all of the
democratic voters
saying print more money they're they're
what we're saying with print more money
is
i want 600 a week plus 100 unemployment
they're saying things like cancel rent
you know forgive loans
they're saying things like pay off all
student debt which is trillions of
dollars
they already printed what six to eight
trillion or something yeah most of the
people on the left are saying just print
print print and there's a meme now money
printer go burr
because they're just cranking out money
you know what that leads to vendors
yes yep man i was in venezuela let me
tell you guys
we had stacks of cash in big black
garbage bags
and you would want to buy like a slice
of pizza if you could even find well
there you go it's like avocado and
chicken it's really delicious actually
and you hand a big old stack of cash big
massive stack they shovel it
into piles that's how worthless it is
yep and that's what happens when they
just
just mass print money so i'm i'm
concerned about what's gonna happen but
i'll tell you what
well the the great meme lord elon musk
he stated just the other day that the
left is losing the middle
yep and he's right and i i can't
these polls man i don't i can't believe
it anymore no
that i don't either i i never did
believe him i
i i just use my gut i have strong
instincts and i i
most americans are seeing this and
they're like this is insanity this
doesn't make any sense
but what happens if they buy an election
but
but but but but i i nah
i'm not i don't even i'm not even going
to do that because i just told you
that's wha
i don't believe that that isn't the case
that they're going to cheat an election
oh there i mean they'll try i mean but
i don't think i don't think they're
gonna succeed too many people want trump
to win too many people think that he's
like
the the answer to counter all of this
because he's going after them all
i guess i guess the thing is
yeah are the pollsters and everything i
i do believe
at this point i really do think they're
lying i think they're calling each other
but the way who do you
who are you voting for well i'm voting
for button well who are you voting for
i'm voting for button too all right the
poll's complete no one else we need to
ask
boom bind's in the wind it's like well i
think enough
i think their methodologies are
completely broken beyond what they even
recognize
yeah and i think it's because they
they've
you know the internet world isn't it is
a new thing i mean look obama
was the first president to use facebook
for campaigning
that was one president to go one wow so
people don't realize that social media's
influence and cell phone technology's
influence
is literally only with donald trump well
that's why
he's pushing the fcc to to reform 230.
yep
yeah so uh when did when did touch cell
phones become ubiquitous ubiquitous 2007
no i don't know i'm not sure when we
started getting phones i could actually
browse the internet i remember
man back in like oh six i'm
skateboarding and i had a candy bar
phone with with garbage mobile internet
you could barely do anything with
yeah then the iphone came out and it was
extremely low resolution but it had
browsers
then obama was president for two terms
and throughout
that cell phones rapidly evolved donald
trump becomes president at a time when
the internet had become substantially
more influential
true this is like we're still in the
model t
era of internet's influence that's a
good that's very right you're
you're absolutely right we are still
babies in the the
someone i don't remember who said this
but it is it is essentially
what you said the model t but it's like
the original telephone
you know when we are first able to
actually communicate
far distances like that was amazing for
the human race like what we were able to
do
and we skyrocketed look at look at the
you know the technological
advances we've made so now the internet
is
the telephone 2.0 for the human race so
we're we're really
not even we don't even know that what
it's doing to our brains you know being
able to definitely breaking them
we're changing them not breaking them
we're we're it's
we're changing we are evolving you know
very
quickly i mean when you're getting used
to the internet you know it's becoming
very second nature to just be like well
let me just look it up
google it well i hate that term but it's
like it's become
so you know second nature for people to
just say that you know oh yeah just
google it and you know you
whatever you don't even need to use
google but now it becomes this thing
well i could just
look up anything i was looking thinking
about
right now i can check it out and look it
up and and boom now i'm suddenly
that much more enlightened there's a
couple really important things that i'm
trying to find real quick
that break down when the big shift in
the internet occurred
and there was the scientist who rejected
he refused
to do an interview with the new york
times where can i find this where is it
at
and the reason he said is that they've
it's basically the whole point about how
they've become
buzzfeed they decided they they got rid
of
actual objective journalism yeah i can't
seem to find it on my timeline i don't
know how long ago it was
it wasn't that long ago it's hard
searching through i know man
it's not even popping up oh that was
annoying
well i do have this one tweet right here
and as
uh zach goldberg tweeted this the new
york times
white people percentage and racism a
percentage
and you can see how they track wow yeah
so this is this
2012. so here's what i said facebook
incentivized shock content like police
brutality videos
blogs started to take notice at what
worked better and ran with shock content
and
justice videos the more keywords stuffed
into a post the farther it would reach
the new york times took notice and
adapted accordingly so
this is what i think the internet has
done it's hyper-polarized everybody yep
now you've got people who are enraged
there's there's the rage
tribe and that's the left they are just
their their identity is anger
yeah it's crazy when somebody will tweet
at me
something like all these nasty things
about me and i try to respond
respond politely in an engaging way and
the only reaction they can have
is spewing vi like you know acid at me
yep so there was a viral post we talked
about the other day at the bill barr
hearings where
this one congresswoman was like bill
barr how did you not know about these
men with guns you know showing up with
confederate flags
i responded to this female journalist i
said but they were on state property
right
weren't they that's all i asked and her
response was
debate me you coward and i was like
what what what what why
why why why proportionate yeah i was
confused why are you insulting me and
why are you asking me to debate i've
never debated anybody
i've done like discussions i'm not i
don't consider myself to be a great
debater at all i wouldn't do it
and then all of a sudden everyone
responded with insults
name calling just psychotic behavior the
same thing happens whenever i tweet at
david pakman or kyle kalinski
and that's why i'm like i'm not gonna do
it kyle kalinski will tweet something
and i'll tweet something that's like in
further into the conversation
and i'll get a thousand tweets of just
swears cusses
slurs and i'm like that to the internet
that that's that's that's how i see the
left
to be honest well i mean it makes sense
like they they've polarized
everybody who is saturated in the
internet so you're either one side or
the other side now they've really like
split us and this is what i don't think
they're
they're taking into consideration not
everybody's on the internet
most of americans were alive and
prospering
before the internet became such a
massive thing that we're now discovering
it's like
this is a new generation that we're
seeing that's why all the people that
are out there
you know throwing bombs and and
complaining
are a younger group like it seems like
they're all in their mid-20s
you know coming out of college maybe
early 30s i don't know but it's like
they were raised on the internet and
they were that exact graph
shows that they were affected by that
you know so they're polarized of course
they're so angry
but most people are not most people are
like what are they doing they're crazy
they're
use your brains rasmussen actually uh
published something recently because
donald trump tweeted
about twitter's bias and all that okay
rasmussen replied by showing that in a
poll they did
the 18 to like 35 or whatever is
uh very likely to be influenced by
social media in terms of politics or
somewhat
and all other demographics were like not
really that much that's exactly what i
would have guessed right yeah exactly
well here's the danger
this is i think why big tech wants to
skew everything as hard to the far left
as possible
because what's going to happen is i've
long explained
i just took the eight values test well
you know it's it's a political alignment
test and guess what
tim poole is a liberal that's what it
said centrist
liberalism that's what i've longed
that's a classic liberal not classic
liberal no
no new age liberalism not not neoliberal
general
liberalism not far left classic explain
that then explain so class what does
that mean
classical liberalism is more towards the
free market than i am i'm more mixed
economy
okay so this is like what liberals were
10
15 years ago yeah that's okay yeah
classical liberal is a reference to like
john locke and like
old school so classical liberal would
refer to like a center-right
position libertarian position okay
social liberal is center left which is
probably
closer to where i am but general
liberalism
so i mean our company our country is is
a liberal country
you know right isn't it based on in the
true sense of the word
yeah true not the colloquial sense of
the word okay but anyways
it seemed to to be changing quite often
now now it's just
the crazy left are the liberals like
libtards but this is the point
come on if the if when the far left says
they're centrists
and they've been saying it over and over
again it's absolutely not
true it's an attempt to shift the whole
wheel
so that someone like me who's actually
center left
will become right wing and they'll
become center that's how i've long
described it you know
tucker carlson did it did a debate with
jen kuger of the young turks and they
agreed on a whole bunch of things about
economic policy
but they will call him far right in what
sense is he far right
yeah someone called me far right
yesterday and i was like wait where what
what
someone on twitter and i'm like like do
you even do you watch a show do you
realize that i'm i'm pretty centered you
know i saw a uh
a truck with a massive don't tread on me
flag
yeah it was massive yeah yeah the gaston
flag
it was it was cool to see it it's a
symbol of liberty i just wanted to throw
that in the air but this is
cool this is what i've long said if
you're someone who
is has traditionally been liberal if you
agreed with bernie sanders in 2015
you are far right no joke bernie sanders
said no to open borders several times no
to free trade several times
they the the world socialist website
called bernie sanders a nationalist
capitalist that's right
and they were right they were bernie
sanders believed in
a welfare state but in a capitalist
market to sustain it
and he believed in protecting our
borders ending free trade deals
and and slowing immigration i liked him
in 2016. and they called him a national
capitalist wow
and then but once it got into 2016 he
started to adopt
more of these weird intersectional
establishment policy ideas
open borders for instance you know what
i think happened bernie sanders said in
2015
open borders is a koch brothers proposal
it's a far right proposal
then donald trump won on the republican
side and the never trumpers
those people bernie sanders were
criticizing jumped over to the democrats
and said we're with you
and so all of a sudden the democrats
started adopting that establishment
politic
so you know i think the democratic
democrats today
are a weird mixture of republican
establishment refugees and democratic
establishment
refugees right they're being attacked by
the far left
because there's a lot of democrats that
i mean i i consider myself a democrat
for a long time i mean i didn't i didn't
i had no idea what i was doing
politically yeah you know so but i know
a lot of people that i'm talking to now
that i'm they're coming to me and like
actual friends of mine they're like
what's up why don't you explain yourself
to me what about this what about this
what about this because i'm a democrat
and i don't understand why this this
this this and this
and i'll straight up talk through all of
them and they're like wow
i agree with you yeah on all of those
things and i'm like yeah
i know it's once you know the truth once
you see what's actually going on it's
it's fairly
straightforward i was talking to crowder
yeah
and i said look man i've all and this
was this was months ago i can't remember
exactly when it was
stephen crowder was unfamiliar uh he's a
conservative comedian
and i was saying things like i've always
considered myself
like a left-leaning independent and i
favor
democrats on a lot of issues never never
really paid attention much to what the
republicans are all about never really
agreed with them
and then he asked me about pro-life and
pro-choice and i said
right this has become a real problem for
me because i grew up catholic
on the south side of chicago yeah and
then my family around the time i was
like
11 or 12 just totally like got away from
the church and became
more agnostic than anything but still
regular americans at least as far as my
family was concerned on the south side
being chicago democrats
thought that being pro-choice meant was
it like safe legal but rare
like abortion should not be something
you celebrate and or
something that you you use as like a
prophylactic yeah exactly it's like like
oops got pregnant better go to the
doctor yeah yeah like that that's gross
you know it's it's like a last resort as
it as like how you just described it it
was supposed to be an extreme
circumstances
that's what it was like growing up in
chicago which is blue
and you know you know they tell they
tell me today well chicago has always
been
conservative democrat that you're
admitting it and i'm like dude chicago
was one of the democrat strongholds
period that will never change
i mean maybe it'll change because of
trump i think it's i think it's changing
man
i i definitely think so well so so here
was the problem that i brought up i'm
talking to crowder about it i'm like
look man
i'm pro-choice for sure but i definitely
agree with tulsi gabbard who
she said there should be limits up to
the third trimester and there's got to
be some kind of
you know line that we can compromise on
yeah i agree and that's why i was like i
like tulsi gabbard yeah
now she she's out and what's the
position
what what did michelle wolf say post i
don't even know it's not
it's no longer gross now it's no longer
pro-choice it's pro-abortion
yeah basically and crowder was like the
republican side right now is negotiating
certain exemptions that's way better
than just
them being like go for it right and i'm
like i guess
yeah so the the what's happening is the
far left has moved so far left
that my the closest thing i could
consider is someone who's
to the right of me because the far left
is gone yep can't even see him anymore
exactly it's like you got to climb up
really really high and look is that them
over there
they're falling off the cliff that's
where we're at of course they say the
opposite but i'll tell you what man
i read the news all day every day if
they're claiming right now they won in
portland
when they're agreeing to the terms of
the dhs and the dhs is saying we're not
going to leave
we've got you got schooled or what was
that what did he say to him something
like that whatever you got you got
got people we won
in a you know fake reality they do
where they have these democratic
politicians saying we want everyone
and they're like yay and then it's like
but they didn't
you know they still can't accept that
trump one they've been screaming
non-stop about it since
2016. surprise he's the president when
are you gonna get that in your head
it's the weirdest thing to me that there
was a meme that said trump is your
president
because people are saying not my
president so the right responded with
yes he is
and i'm like why is it so hard to say
trump's your president i was like i
didn't vote for him i wasn't a fan of
him yeah you can say you know he's my
president he's still the president
that's so weird he still got there he's
he still is there
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 p.m if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode